what's the dream fight for you dream
fight man i'll say this enough you sound
like everyone everyone says all right
conor mcgregor everyone's going to say
that right i'm but i'm thinking that
that's the [ __ ] yeah well you guys are
going to strike yep right you're going
to go at it you can come up to whatever
but i'm thinking that's the fight man
well like uh yeah man just remember i've
fought every other champion i beat every
other champion in my division right he's
the only other champion that i haven't
beat so uh you know beat aldo uh max
holloway and uh con is the only other
champion in my division and i've been
saying i want all the legends of my
division all the all the top guys in my
division i want to take them all out
that's why uh zombie
i mean well he won't make featherweight
ever again so what do you think can he
make 155 i thought he meant anything
170. don't matter
that's my that's what i've been
wondering you were obviously 200 pounds
before ufc how comfortable are you high
going up and still fighting yet i
probably couldn't get uh higher than uh
170 now 170 is probably my that's yeah
he could obviously go down lower so we
wouldn't have to one second what would
you know if that was the oh it has to be
this
whatever let's do it so and as his
comeback fight or do you think he's not
ready for that i think he's dumb to take
it as his first fight back whenever i
was obviously i know for you yeah yeah
whatever but i mean obviously i want him
in good nick yeah i want him uh you know
i don't want him to have excuses do you
think he looks good on the pads have you
seen any of those videos of him like him
i haven't watched too much i think i
might have seen her a little bit what do
you look like
like his
back for me the thing about connor was
like wow you have legit speed and and
head movement that's the thing that's
always impressive is like to be able to
like move his head off the line
four inches you know a lot of guys are
making these like big dips yeah it's so
hard to recover from a big dip but it's
like that counter left that he would
always throw that he would catch people
early on yep he's moving his head off
barely and
i just see him he's now he's kind of
like stocky and big what the [ __ ] do i
know i'm the fighter but like are you
onto something there yeah i'm hearing
you you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
here now and i just i think it'd be dumb
of him to take a first fight back
against you i might also be trying to
play into his ego so he tight plays yeah
[Laughter]
don't you think i mean i don't know i
think that's the one yeah oh man for
sure you know again like you've got the
circus and all that around it you know
what i mean it's
it's a no-brainer for anyone want that
but again
there's a we've got a bit more on on top
of that the fact that he's another
another champion of my division so uh
and yeah i think uh yeah things are
going pretty good so
i think it could be maybe not next
like you said i don't know if he's
coming in anytime soon yeah i want a
couple of fights this year but later in
the year
who else who else i mean the max fights
were incredible mm-hmm dude you [ __ ]
dug down on that first one bro when you
just started taking him down
and what was it i loved this the second
one you mean the fought alone no i think
the first fight remember it was in the
fourth or f it was in the fourth or
fifth fourth the first one was uh in
vegas the second fight was
uh well that was that's when i took him
down in the in the last but it was just
like max was having success
and
you were like i'm gonna do what it takes
to win this fight yeah yeah that's kind
of what it seemed like yeah it was
obviously if it didn't start well yeah
yeah it didn't start well but i mean uh
that's just the type of guy i am you
know i mean i think look at all that
adversities have been obviously the the
chokes were talking about yeah uh and
then being behind and then having to be
like oh [ __ ] dig deep and then
out work guys they're known for their
cardio too max is known for it you know
what i mean so when you've got to dig
deep and do things i'm showing
so much range in in uh my capabilities
with things like that you know what i
mean
even with the chin where you know
obviously even chad mendes yeah catch
him catching my chin and all that type
of stuff but i got back up and yeah
right back in his face and crumbled him
straight after that yeah that's the
thing about like beating legends
is
max goes on to continue to be great
because he's a legend too
and the better that people see max
the better they see your wins over a guy
like max you know what i mean like it's
it's interesting it's like your legacy
also lies in the legacy of the people
you've defeated history works in
hindsight so it's always looking back
what did they do and that yeah i mean i
just love max i think he's [ __ ] i
think he's [ __ ] great but i'd like
another one of that what else though
what else well that's that's something
that was meant to happen yeah yeah yeah
that's this fight that's why zombie got
it because he got injured yeah so that's
a big fight that's always going to be
there as well and uh again we just need
i don't know the situation i don't know
uh how he is with his injury or whatever
but i mean uh that's a fight that people
still want to see what they're called
the right decision for the right time
and a lot of people still want to see it
colby we're going to colby i'll fly
colby 170. yeah do you make him come
down maybe a catch i'll do it you know
what i mean i mean whether they'd be
like you know welterweight and
featherweight they probably wouldn't
make it happen but i'll do it yeah you
would guarantee i would yeah so it's uh
with fights like that as well you go up
and move up two divisions sort of
win-win anyway you know what i mean you
go there even though i think i'll do i
could still do all right even against
these big boys yeah you don't
yeah nobody's back down to lightweight
and featherweight you know what i mean
like that's why you've got a lot of guys
that want to move up
they think they're like you know but i
mean they're doing that because it's a
there's no they can go back to division
like oh you know they i took the risk by
doing this so it's a win-win for them
they win yeah
soaking it up they lose i'll go back oh
you know look i was one taking massive
risks and stuff that's that's just how
it is
[Applause]